South Carolina Senator Lindsey Graham
Senator you know I watched Chuck Schumer
today and it was it was good to finally
hear him speak out he spoke out
powerfully against
anti-Semitism uh I'm sure a lot of it
directed at his own party uh where was
he when Congress woman to leave was
saying you know to wipe Israel off the
map from The River To The Sea and why
did Chuck Schumer there was a standalone
Aid bill for Israel on the senate floor
yesterday and he I'm told was leading
the effort to stop that Aid bill is that
correct sir that's exactly right so uh
Senator schimer made an eloquent
presentation about the rise of
anti-Semitism and he's right about that
so what happened here is 3911 for Israel
occurred on October the 7th 1 1200 Jews
were slaughtered in their homes the
biggest killing of the Jewish people
since the Holocaust and you have an
Oakland California people praising Hamas
the Democratic party supports the
Palestinians over the Israel ises for
the first time in polling last year so
this effort by my Democratic colleagues
to put restrictions on money going to
Israel to defend thems is sick and
absurd this call for a ceasefire uh it
is nuts what would we have said to a
group that asked us to have a ceasefire
after 911 we told them to go to hell so
here's what I say to my Democratic
colleagues support Israel without uh
conditions allow them to destroy Hamas
uh before it's too late for the Jewish
State stand with Israel reject Hamas
tell all these crazy people to shut up
the bottom line here is the Republican
party is with Israel the Democratic
party uh is very confused well I mean I
I really don't understand why Washington
works this way uh I understand well okay
fair answer um but you know I know what
Chuck wants to do here he wants to tie
funding for Israel to funding for
Ukraine for funding with Taiwan and
maybe he'll give some money to the
Border uh the house is not going to go
along with that period in sence I don't
see that happening uh Israel has not
gotten any Aid money Ukraine has gotten
nearly 80 billion dollar of money we're
paying more than Europe is paying it's
their continent that is at War um and I
I think that's been unfair on their part
my question is why can't we vote on
every bill as a standalone on the merits
up or down
and why are these games always played he
if he's so concerned about Israel he had
an opportunity to help them yesterday
and he passed on that opportunity yeah
so we need to bring up an Israel
Standalone uh Bill and support Israel
and be be done with it but I'm not going
to give money to foreign countries until
we secure our own border 10 Democratic
senators wrote a letter uh opposing
efforts to uh provide border security
opposing policy changes that would
secure our border Governor Abbott if
you're watching Shan Hannity tonight do
me a favor make it real to those 10
senators in their states which you've
been dealing with in Texas instead of
sending them all to New York why don't
you look at the states in question uh uh
Rhode Island Connecticut Oregon governor
Abbott make it real to these 10 Senators
what it's like to live with a broken
border send thousands of illegal
immigrants to make it real to the
politicians who oppose uh border
security the Democratic position is
remain in Texas they're okay with Texas
being overrun Governor Abbott send
busloads of legal immigrants to these
Senators so they will understand what
it's like to live with a broken border
let me ask you Senator um we we hear
this virulent anti-Semitism in the halls
of Congress we see it on you know
college universities prestigious
universities a lot of them uh we see it
in the streets of our cities we are
seeing it worldwide all across Europe
we're seeing it even in Australia uh gas
the Jews F the Jews did you ever think
In Our Lifetime that we'd ever hear
those words in light of the history of
what happened in Nazi Germany because
that sounds like the 1930s to me and
I've never used that analogy very often
I thought it was often misused and
overused I don't think so in this case
based on the knowledge we have of the
acts they committed that are on
videotape frankly that I would like to
air uh except I'm sure it would be too
harmful for the families unless we pixel
out their faces well I'm going to call
people at Fox tomorrow and beg them to
put on the air uh some of the videos so
you can see for yourself what happened
to the Jewish people you can see that on
October the 7th 2023 80 years after the
war so Uprising in Poland Hamas wants to
kill all the Jews for religious reasons
the Nazis wanted to kill all the Jews
because of racial reasons I never
thought I would live to see a holocaust
Survivor who survived the Nazi Terror to
be killed by Hamas in Israel we live in
dangerous and sick times uh I am begging
Fox to air the footage so the American
people can see what Israel is facing no
conditions on Israel a to my friends in
Israel do what you need to do as long as
it takes to defend your country to the
Palestinian people turn on Hamas kick
them out
Lindsay you know Israel well you've been
over there many times I've been there
many times I've been in the terror
tunnels I know you've been in the terror
tunnels uh I've I've I've been near the
Iron Dome I've seen it work I've been to
border towns like St uh 10,000 Miss
Rockets they got hit with in a 10year
period of time kids can't play outside
they play in underground bunker
playgrounds and and I'm thinking Victory
to me is this if it once and for all God
can no longer be a launching pad for
Rockets into Israel but that also
includes in the North Lebanon can no
longer be a launching pad either if they
want to have real security and peace in
the region and security for Israel but
I'll say this nobody seems to ever want
to talk about the number one state
sponsor of Terror and that is Iran that
we now know they trained Hamas for this
they supplied them with Weaponry for
this they are fighting another proxy war
one of many in the region they have been
forting Terror and getting away with it
for a long period of time I would say it
might be time for the world to realize
in the entire region that maybe those
refineries that that Joe uh has allowed
them to use more than Donald Trump did
maybe those refineries need to go maybe
those nuclear facilities maybe they need
to go before they get nuclear weapons
well so we've been on your show a lot
talking about this how do you protect
American troops in Syria and Iraq you
attack Iran when we're attacked in Syria
and Iraq by Iranian proxies this Biden
Administration is incredibly weak nobody
respects them nobody's afraid of them
let me tell our friends in Egypt and the
United Arab Emirates if you go into
bricks and join an organization made up
of Iran Russia and China you're going to
make an enemy me let me tell my friends
in Saudi Arabia I want you to normalize
with Israel I'd like to have a strategic
relationship with you but if you join
bricks an organization basically
controlled by Russia uh China and Iran
uh you will be an enemy of the United
States Biden has lost all respect and
all fear to the Iranians if you kill one
American in Syria and Iraq and I know
you're trying to through your proxies I
will do everything I can to make sure
you're hit in return to the Republican
party let's stand up for Israel without
equivocation let's put pressure on the
Biden Administration and protect our
troops President Biden does not have the
backs of those serving in Syria and Iraq
Mr president President Biden you need to
let the Iranians know if you keep trying
to kill Americans we're coming after you
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else